[Music]
you have no idea do you what did you
choose not to know your husband stole
two million dollars for me
[Music]
this is about my life
[Music]
this is about my life
because it's about my life and that
becomes about yours
so don't delay something better
mr. Moloch and your family's been
involved in Harry's life for many years
I need help I don't see what I can do
our husbands aren't coming back
raaaah my husband left me the plans for
his next job
well honey it is cool to pull it off why
should we trust you anyway because I'm
the only one standing between you and a
bullet in your head that's what I've
learned from men like your late husband
and my father is that you reap what you
sow let's hope so
[Applause]
[Music]
this is for guns guns from where figure
it out
if this whole thing goes wrong I want my
kids to know that I didn't just sit
there and take it
I did something
[Music]
[Music]
now the best thing we have going for is
is being who we are why because no one
thinks we have the balls to pull this
off
Harry Rollins never mess with me I know
my smell get different games always have
respect so why do you hear me now no oh
no what thinks you send your sights on
some high are you getting sloppy miss
Rawlings Jack Mulligan I had the
privilege of working with your husband a
couple of times he was a wonderful man
I'm so sorry for your loss if there's
anything I can do please don't hesitate
to ask I'm not a hard man to find and
God bless
solved our problem
what's this this is Belle she's fast
she's smart and she can drive well we
can't do this the three of us we need a
driver this is not your place please ask
her to leave I'm standing here the
doctor man I don't know you you don't
have to I'm happy to leave right now we
need a driver
your girl's happy to split your cut
split bar cut its equal or nothing you
vouch for her I don't require about
we're gonna need another gun I got my
own you need to watch how you talk to me
if you end we need to get you started
right away Argo Davis in three days the
night at the debate now all of our work
is worth nothing if we don't move this
money and fast the note book says five
million dollars that's exactly the
amount of money Mulligan was accused of
taken in commission kickbacks
so over here we have two million dollars
twenty Tupperware boxes each box is a
hundred thousand dollars and $100 bills
it weighs 44 pounds now over here we
have two million dollars 40 Tupperware
boxes each box has $50,000 and $50 bills
it weighs 88 pounds feel like I'm in
school tell me better we gotta start
thinking like professionals we're in
business together there's not gonna be
some cozy reunion after this job we're
done we have three days to look and move
like a team of men the best thing we
have going for us as being who we are
why because no one thinks we have the
balls to pull this off
how far have we fallen
the less you know the more seemingly you
gain something happened something bad
[Music]
with us was a TV series but I saw as a
kid 983 it had a impact on me then line
you I want to make that into the night
reaches up after 12 years the films
about these four women whose husbands
died during this attempted heist when
you meet Veronica she's left with
nothing in terms of finances and nothing
in terms of emotional reserve he stole
two million dollars from me
that money was meant to buy me a new
life because it's about my life now
becomes about yours these are that are
dealing with all four stuff and then
they come together and have to deal with
it together we're in trouble now husband
stole a lot of money and now people want
it from us Harry left me the plans for
his next job it's worth five million
dollars
why should we trust you anyway because
I'm the only one standing between you
and the bullet in your head
widows is a story of survival everything
sort of feels like it's on this knife
there's a door in or out out and you
take your chances with the Mannings in
and there's no going back it's dangerous
it's messy and it's real the best thing
we have going for is is being who we are
why because no one thinks we have the
balls to pull this off that's so
this is a really tough ass movie it's
very suspenseful and twisty and turny
but this whole thing goes wrong
I know what the consequences look like
what I've learned from this city is that
you reap what you sow
let's hope so what has happened in the
world that normal now passes as
excellence when did we lower our
standards we are living in an
environment where people are blind what
you don't see you don't know
out of sight
something happened today something bad
our husbands aren't coming back
Ronna
[Music]
there's no a lot of money and now people
want it from us
now the best thing we have going for is
this being who we are why because no one
thinks we have the balls to pull this
off
we've in this world got you down on your
knees
if this whole thing goes wrong I want my
kids to know that I didn't just sit
there and take it
I did something in this city reap what
you sow
let's hope so
[Music]
[Applause]
the best thing we have going for us is
being who we are why because no one
thinks we have the balls to pull this
off whenever Steve McQueen sees the
scene I always see him getting to the
very nucleus of what the truth of it is
I think that when people see this
they're gonna really be in it they're
gonna believe it our husbands aren't
coming back
Ron Oh they stole a lot of money and now
people wanted from the scene from us
from you it's a very complex story and
it's a personal vision of the director
Steve McQueen hi
my husband left me the plans for his
next job all he'll need is a cool to
pull it off
he's an artist through and through each
scene we do isn't our piece why should
we trust you anyway because I'm the only
one standing between you and a bullet in
your head
I just have so much respect for what he
has in his mind and then just being able
to see how that translates on the screen
is a real gift if this whole thing goes
wrong I want my kids to know that I
didn't just sit there and take it
I did something he's not interested in
you being comfortable he's interested in
what makes that audience lean in what
I've learned in this city that you reap
what you sow
let's hope so
[Music]
you